journal dans un quart d'heure tout de
suite la revue de presse
avec vous excellent mais ce matin
bonjour axel à la une de la presse
internationale axel le président
ukrainien en pleine tournée diplomatique
car visioconférence forcément c'était
hier ses parlementaires italiens que
vaut le diminuera zelensky s'est adressé
et c'est là une vous allez l'avoir du
corriere della serra voilà cette une du
corriere avec écrit à utah taî-chi aidez
nous c'est une étape décisive de notre
politique étrangère est à bien des
égards un tournant explique le corriere
pendant 20 ans une partie importante de
la classe politique italienne à espérer
de diverses manières pouvoir être ami
avec poutine et donc recevoir de lui un
traitement spécial dans ce même
parlement où il hier le président
ukrainien a accusé je cite un toujours
l'autocrate de moscou d'être le seul
responsable du carnage dans son pays eh
bien il ya de nombreuses forces
politiques qui siègent dans ce parlement
qui s'était vanté d'une relation
spéciale avec poutine poursuivre le
corriere della serra on sait toute
l'admiration personnelle de berlusconi à
la limite de la vénération l'italie hier
la france aujourd'hui séance
exceptionnelle au parlement écrit
libération le président ukrainien qui
servent à ça donc aux députés et aux
sénateurs pour demander plus
d'assistance il avait entamé sa tournée
diplomatique virtuel par le parlement
européen le 1er mars rappelle libération
il l'a poursuivie au canada puis devant
la chambre des communes britannique le
congrès américain et c est devant chaque
auditoire volodymyr alinsky a su invoqué
les figures à même de galvaniser le
public martin luther king et son rêve
devant les américains shakespeare et
churchill devant les britanniques
zelensky est aussi passé maître dans
l'art d'appuyer là où ça fait mal
continue à libération un de mettre ses
interlocuteurs en face de leurs
contradictions de leurs petites
compromissions où l'acheter une guerre
de communication que le président
ukrainien maîtrise parfaitement oui
c'est là une de l'opinion là comme
l'autre guerre 2 zelensky il met son
talent au service de la cause celui du
comédien du champion de stand up qu'il
était avant d'être élu à la présidence
de son pays il ya trois ans et le
contraste est fort 1 poursuit l'opinion
avec vladimir poutine fermé sur lui-même
qui ne s'adresse qu'aux seuls russe en
pointant du doigt d'éventuels traite par
mieux et puis vous avez vu sur cette
caricature on voit poutine avec un
téléphone portable il est écrit il dit
ce bombardement médiatique est
insoutenable cac pour l'opinion sur le
terrain militaire on en parlait dans le
journal à l'instant les états unis
semblent voir des signes de pardon que
l'ukraine passe à l'offensive là vous
avez d'ailleurs la photo de khamis est
le porte parole du pentagone les
troubles ukrainienne et c'est washington
post les troupes du crânienne semble de
plus en plus entreprendre des opérations
contre les forces d'invasion russes ont
déclaré hier des responsables américains
de la défense or jusqu'à présent les
américains se sont montrés bien informés
sur ce qui se passe dans cette région à
les ukrainiens tenterez de regagner du
territoire en particulier dans le sud
poursuit le washington post dans des
villes comme personne un autre
responsable sous couvert d'anonymat mais
un bémol un relève le washington post
c'est difficile de dire si cela marque
une contre offensive majeure ce que les
américains perçoivent sur le terrain
dans la presse également ce matin le
qu'ovide 19 qui fait toujours des vagues
et vous allez regarder la une de
20minutes photos prises
je pense le tas dans l'aéroport de
roissy vague à l'art avec un jeu de mots
depuis le début du mois les
contaminations repartent à la hausse en
france faut-il s'inquiéter se demande 20
minutes qui rappelle qu'il ya eu au
moins cinq reprises en deux ans et puis
jamais avare de deux jeux de mots 20
minutes explique aussi que c'est un
mauvais films de la nouvelle vague et et
ce n'est évidemment pas franco-français
comme constat exemple vie indépendante
le nombre de passions du coc vit en
angleterre dans les autres dans les
hôpitaux anglais a augmenté d'une
semaine en 20 % 10 1% en une semaine et
le gouvernement ne peut pas prétendre
que la menace du coc vide a disparu
avertissent les dirigeants du service de
santé britannique
dans un registre moins dramatique cette
stupeur en italie la numéro un mondiale
du tennis prend sa retraite à 25 ans de
l'australie en l'occurrence là
effectivement le sydney herald tribune
titre sur ashley bharti c'est vraiment
elle a la une de toute la presse
australienne ce matin ashleigh barty qui
annonce sa retraite choc du tennis
numéro un mondial vainqueur de roland
garros en 2019 de wimbledon l'an dernier
de l'open d'australie cette année elle a
annoncé donc sa retraite dans une vidéo
postée sur les réseaux sociaux pourquoi
si jeune alors eh bien le sydney herald
tribune dit qu'elle n'avait plus envie
d'ailleurs elle expliqué dans sa vidéo
ni l'envi physique ni la volonté de
continuer à jouer et de se maintenir au
sommet du tennis féminin et on apprend
aussi qu'elle a commencé à envisager sa
retraite des wimbledon son wimbledon
victorieux l'an dernier donc une star du
tennis qui s'en va et une pluie
d'étoilés en cuisine je terminerais là
dessus la toute première cérémonie hors
de paris du guide michelin a eu lieu à
cognac hier dans le sud ouest et le
journal local la charente libre puisque
qu'une extension rentes se réjouit
cognac au plus près des étoiles l'espace
d'une journée ensoleillée cognac aura
été la capitale de la gastronomie
française de nouveau trois étoiles la
récompense suprême de nouveau trois
étoiles ont été accordés l'un pour
arnaud donckele à paris et l'autre pour
dimitri de brno et sa femme marie elle a
près de marseille il ya désormais trente
et une table trois étoiles en france bah
vous m'invitez quand vous voulez merci
pour égaliser elle a tout à la hausse et